in the human eye there are three color
receptors the colors we see are a
mixture of signals from these receptors
integrated by the brain the mantis
shrimp does things a little differently
these colorful coral dwellers have 12
color receptors but that doesn't mean
they see four times as many colors as we
do researchers figured this out by
training a mantis to grab for food tied
to tiny colored lights mantis shrimp
were not very good at discriminating
between lights that were very close in
color they could detect about a twenty
five nanometer difference in wavelength
basically they can tell pure orange from
pure yellow our eyes can perceive a four
nanometer difference in wavelength the
mantis shrimp scan their environment and
take quick yes-no readings
instead of integrating signals from
their color receptors like we do they
can speedily identify colors but they
don't tune the readings by comparing
input from different receptors this is a
fundamentally different way of seeing
color but it doesn't let them see more
colors in case you're starting to doubt
the amazingness of the mantis shrimp
have no fear in addition to color vision
they can also see UV light and two kinds
of polarized light
you